on the sidelines of the United Nations
General Assembly the Canadian Prime
Minister repeated his charge that there
was credible evidence that agents of the
Indian government were responsible for
the killing of a Canadian Sikh activist
on Canadian soil we call upon the
government of India to engage with us to
move forward on getting to the truth of
this matter
the Indian government calls the
allegations absurd but also added that
it was unclear what exactly is being
alleged we are willing to look at any
specific information that is provided to
us but so far we have not received any
such specific information it's a
sentiment that's being increasingly
heard in Canada as well if there was
sufficient evidence to publicly accuse
the Indian government of murder and
expel an Indian Diplomat why can't it be
released
there is a growing sense of our knees
here at the lack of evidence provided by
Canadian authorities and the lack of
vocal support for ottawa's claims from
its key allies with that okay the US's
caution and calls for conclusions not to
be drawn prematurely even though its
intelligence sharing partner Canada has
already made the accusation have been
widely noted and remarked upon leading
to this statement from the White House I
firmly reject the idea that there is a
wedge between the US and Canada we have
deep concerns about the allegations and
we would like to see this investigation
carried forward as a longtime MP and
former premier of British Columbia
udrell dosange had his confrontations
with a large Sikh separatist population
in the province expressing his
opposition to their sometimes violent
rhetoric he also feels that the
allegations may have substance but
thinks the Prime Minister has completely
mishandled them you don't make such a
serious
uh statement
with uh you know serious allegations
against
another government
and then have no evidence to back it up
with
um and your allies don't stand with you
the sad part is that he took the largest
arrow out of his quiver and fired it and
now there's not much more he can do
Trudeau may now have the Gratitude of
some in Canada's large Sikh population
but is increasingly isolated elsewhere
Shia britansi Al Jazeera Vancouver
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera